it says product of Thailand I think this
is a Japanese treat that's why I've had
them since I was a little kid because
I'm Japanese but I thought they were
Chinese because I've had them since a
little kid well you've been lied to your
whole life I love it I didn't know if
they're called either when you just said
Pocky Alec how do you spell that again
my mom was picking me Pocky from the
umbilical cord that's how long I've been
talking for I just love Pocky as a snack
because it's like not too sweet and not
messy and you can just stick is truly
the best shape for snack yeah
variety is the spice of life and today
I'm excited to see what you have to
throw at me but nothing will be
chocolate flavoured Pocky Oh cookies and
cream [ __ ] okay this might be
chocolate I love cookies and cream ice
cream it is just like but wrapped around
a wooden stick it's very standard this
is a standard Pocky its Pocky plus my
favorite flavor I think it's great okay
nice mmm I thought this was good as a
novelty but I would rather have normal
Pocky looks pretty though and I can't
finish the stick
it doesn't really turn me on I'm glad
doesn't
oh it has a great great sin like it
really does smell like green tea
it looks like slime on a stick I love
matcha oh that is a strong matcha flavor
yeah yeah it's great
that's perfect there's green tears like
seaweed in it yeah this tastes a little
grassy I like green tea better than the
other yeah ten pockets out of pockys Aki
is batting a hundred percent right now
this is great that smells like a fresh
grove of strawberries it smells like
that gum that comes it looks like teeth
this smells like the medicine you take
when you're sick in your kid I'm so
happy it's great I'm down for this one
yeah thank you how often do you get to
like say oh I really just had a moment
today and that's what this is giving me
it tastes like dried strawberries then
like cereal mmm I like it chocolate
banana banana cream covered chocolate
biscuit sticks wait you're in an awfully
biscuit sticky yellow it is I want to
liked it to be like drizzled with
chocolate like it is on the packet
where's the chocolate as a banana every
time I have banana flavored things Mike
what what a weird flavor I'm gonna take
another bite I'm like it draws me in
this is probably the worst pocket labor
of all existence
I'm John papaki shout out to all the
kids that share their puppies on the
schoolyard I like the original talking
the best I think matcha is hands-down
the best flavor of Pocky but that's not
surprising because much of the best
flavor of anything true this is true I
think this was a great experience I
enjoyed every single one of them I'd buy
them all again they were all a delight